[Musique]
je buvais un verre avec une amie il n'ya
pas longtemps
elle me disait qu'elle était allée dans
l'usiné je travaillais il ya une
quinzaine d'années elle avait rencontré
les membres de mon équipe et quand ils
ont parlé de moi et le ronde et ils lui
ont dit magali c'est la dernière chef
qu'on a eus qu'il y avait des couilles
j'étais un peu surprise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais pas pour vous mais moi j'aime
bien qu'on se souvienne de moi comme une
personne engageante humaine aspirante
mais alors comme le concept des
attributs masculins j'vous généraux pas
pensé à l'époque je dirigeais une unité
de 60 personnes ont fabriqué des outils
de haute technologie qui devait
descendre dans le puits de pétrole est
arrivé de l'ingénierie un nouvel outil
alors la superstar des outils l'outil
qui allait tout changer qu'elle est tout
révolutionner les spotlights ont sur
nous mais l'outil n'est pas prêt et là
je prends une décision que personne
n'avait osé prendre avant je décide
d'arrêter la production crime de lèse
majesté
je me met à dos toute ma hiérarchie est
certainement le reste du monde
d'ailleurs ils ont juste pas osé de le
dire mais j'étais du bon et j'ai eu
raison parce que qu'on a repris la
production huit mois plus tard on les a
sortis comme des petits pains au
pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça je
raconte tout ça parce que ce que je
voudrais c'est de partager avec vous ce
soir c'est comment cette petite fille
celle là prise sous son meilleur angle
est devenue cette femme-là photo prise
il ya six mois en inde où cette femme là
c'est la même alors revenons par où ça
commence et l'enfance une enfance
heureuse à la campagne je suis une fille
de la campagne issus de la classe
moyenne
un papa féministe mais qui n'a jamais su
faire à manger
coucou papa il abat une maman
institutrice en bref des parents qui
m'ont donné des valeurs de dépassement
de soi mais surtout de la liberté de
pensée puis je fais le lycée et comme
beaucoup de monde je fais des petits
jobs d'été pour gagner de l'argent
et là ça m'apprend que je veux être
actrice de ma vie et je me dis que
finalement le meilleur moyen de faire ça
c'est d'avoir un diplôme
donc je fais une école d'ingénieurs
pendant mon école d'ingénieurs je
remonte un projet avec un prof et je
pars au mali aider des femmes à acquérir
une indépendance financière en faisant
du savon pourquoi pas et ça ça m'a
vraiment donné le goût de l'exploit mais
surtout le goût de la non routine du
voyage et c'est comme ça que je me suis
retrouvé à 22 ans a crapahuté sur une
plate forme pétrolière au nigeria en
pleine mer seule femme avec 81 hommes
j'ai fait plein d'autres choses j'ai
vécu sur quatre continents
j'ai dirigé des milliers de personnes
j'ai eu des budgets avec tellement de
chiffres que je n'arrivais pas à les
compter et puis je suis devant vous ce
soir ça ça compte aussi
et donc comment cette petite fille a
fait tout ça je suis sûr vous vous le
demandez vous aussi tous
eh ben c'est finalement je me suis dit
c'est peut-être ça c'est parce qu'elle
en a je suis allé voir dans le
dictionnaire ce que ça veut dire quand
même l on a ça existe vous trouverez la
définition ça veut dire avoir de du
caractère de l'audace de l'énergie du
courage et là je me suis dit ouais c'est
pas mal comme des filles sur sa me
fabien c'est bien le fil conducteur qui
a conduit non seulement ma vie
personnelle mais aussi mais vie
professionnelle par contre quand même
revenir sur le mot courage soyons clairs
je ne suis pas une héroïne de série b
l'année dernière quand mon mari et mes
filles ont décidé de sauter au bout d'un
élastique dans des gorges magnifique en
nouvelle zélande
moi je suis resté assis sagement sur la
plate forme après il fallait bien que
quelqu'un prenne des photos aussi donc
dont le courage on est vraiment dans le
courage de questionner l'ordre établi
alors ça a commencé il ya 30 ans j'étais
donc en école d'ingénieur et puis je
rencontre ce jeune homme qui est
ingénieur sur plate forme pétrolière au
fin fond de la jungle au brésil je tombe
complètement folle amoureuse de son job
et donc quand les entreprises viennent
visiter mon école line ça je vais
directement aux stands je vois le
recruteur et le recruteur ils me
regardent comme ça il me dit non dans
cette est évidemment il voulait dire
c'est impossible pour une femme de faire
ce métier moi ce nom je me suis pris en
pleine figure et je les traduis c'est
impossible d'accepter que parce que je
suis une femme je ne puisse faire ce
métier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je vais demander de me donner la
raison sauf que même à l'époque on
pouvait pas dire à quelqu'un tu ne peux
pas avoir ce job parce que tu es une
femme
donc je lui demandais en gros de mme
expliquer l'inexplicable
et j'ai fait ça pendant deux heures je
n'ai pas bougé je les ai eus à l'usure
quand de guerre lasse il a fini par
motorisés à postuler
et heureusement que j'ai fais ça parce
que je serai pas aujourd'hui devant vous
et puis franchement voilà ce qu'on
aurait raté
quand même ça aurait été dommage mais
c'était une grande leçon sntn leçon qui
a gouverné le reste de ma carrière et
comme disait le reste de ma vie où je
n'accepte pas l'ordre établi
tout bêtement donc quand j'arrive dans
un nouveau poste une nouvelle situation
je ne pars pas du principe que la façon
dont on le fait et forcément la
meilleure parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
fait d'ailleurs là je crois que la
phrase que gts le plus au monde c'est on
a toujours fait comme ça ça je ne
supporte pas alors comment dans la
pratique comment ça se passe déjà
faudrait il faut avoir un esprit curieux
ouverts et puis ne pas hésiter quand
garde à une nouvelle situation
avoir des idées farfelues parce que le
monde évolue tellement vite que le
farfelu d'hier c'est la norme de demain
et c'est comme ça qu'on fait changer les
choses et ensuite il faut regarder s'il
ya des obstacles parce que les obstacles
ça peut arrêter une belle idée d
identifier et essayer de voir ce qu'on
peut faire là dessus
alors pour les obstacles j'ai une
méthode absolument infaillible ça
s'appelle la méthode des 5 pourquoi
c'est une méthode qui m'a été très
fortement inspiré par ma petite nièce de
trois ans c'est pour dire à quel point
elle est bonne cette méthode on dit
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi jusqu'à temps
qu'on ait trouvé le noeud du problème
je vais donner un exemple j'étais en
chine je dirigeais une usine
j'avais beaucoup de femmes cadres mais
je l'avais aucune femme ouvrière
donc je leur ai posé la question et
m'ont dit c'est simple c'est impossible
d'avoir des femmes ouvrières parce qu'il
n'ya pas de candidates et pourquoi n'y
at il pas de candidates parce que c'est
un métier qui l'interpellé femmes et
pourquoi nana na na na parce que ça me
dit trop dur et pourquoi nena parce que
103 8 et pourquoi c'est un problème le
3,8 et même parce que elles doivent
rentrer tard le soir et c'est dangereux
donc là je suis parti du premier
problème qui était un problème quasi
insoluble on a pas de femmes candidates
c'est impossible d'en trouver à il faut
assurer la sécurité des femmes quand
elle rentre chez elle le soir et ça je
sais faire
et c'est d'autant mieux faire qu'à
l'époque on avait un bus qui le soit
ramené les ouvriers dans leur village
vont il a suffi de demander au chauffeur
de s'arrêter devant le chaque maison de
chaque femme pour s'assurer qu'elle
rentrait en toute sécurité
et puisque j'aime bien cette méthode
c'est que ça marche ça marche pour tout
ça marche dans la sphère privée
également
j'avais une fille qu'il rangeait pas sa
chambre alors là je vois les yeux qui
s'allument va-t-elle nous révéler là
tout de suite maintenant le secret sur
comment faire qu'une ado range sa
chambre maintenant j'ai pas voulu
révéler ce que si je le sais si je
l'avais ben je vous le voudrez je serai
très riche
par contre on a décidé avec ma fille de
ba de jouer au jeu du pourquoi alors
pourquoi tu ranges pas ta chambre
parce que j'aime pas plier parce que ça
prend trop de temps parce que les pistes
on trouve cros mes piles de vêtements
parce que je plie pas de manière assez
régulière donc maintenant j'ai plus qu'à
régler le problème
je n'oublie pas de manière régulière
alors elle a trouvé sur internet ça
s'appelle un traceur d'habitude ce
passionné qui connaissent en tout cas
c'est un truc où on écrit ce qu'on a
décidé de faire à chaque fois qu'on le
fait on met une croix maintenant me
demandez surtout pas pourquoi une ado
est motivé à ranger sa chambre parce
qu'elle voit des croix sur un tableau
mais ça marche on va revenir dans le
monde du travail
on sait bien gentil je n'arrête pas de
vous parler de changement de remettre en
cause plein de choses
bah oui mais il ya des chefs parfois et
les chefs là dedans on en fait quoi
parce que bas les chefs déjà 6,1 pas
beaucoup sortir de sa zone de confort et
puis surtout la petite magazine elle est
en train de venir leur dire qu'elle veut
remettre en cause un autre qu'eux mêmes
ont établi donc il faut travailler son
projet il n'y a pas de vie pas de
miracle dans la vie y'a pas de secret on
travaille on travaille on fait son
projet on trouve les leviers qui vont
motiver les chefs
ensuite on applique le plus de gens
possible pas parce que plus on est de
fous plus on rit mais surtout parce que
comme ça
si jamais le chef veut aller se
renseigner le ou la chef d'ailleurs
s'ils veulent se renseigner maeva
trouver des abris concordants et puis on
choisit le bon moment c'est quand même
bête de gâcher l'idée du siècle parce qu
on la présentait après huit heures de
réunion en petit truc en plus moi ce que
je fais dans ces cas là c'est que je
bloque leur dans mon agenda avant la
réunion pour être sûrs d'être bien
étendu ne pas être stressé
alors après pour la détente c'est vous
qui voyez nenê qui fonde la méditation
l'autre c'est le choc de votre cas mais
je vous laisse libre de choisir alors la
conclusion de tout ça c'est que défier
l'impossible avoir le courage de
questionner l'ordre établi pour moi
c'est ce qui fait la différence entre
une carrière dite normale et une
carrière qui sort de l'ordinaire
et si je reviens la petite fille là une
fois qu'elle aura fini sa galipettes et
que je vous demande de regarder un peu
ce que j'ai fait cette carrière où j'en
suis aujourd'hui je crois qu'elle serait
fière de moi mais serais pas fier de moi
à cause des postes que j'ai eus non elle
serait fier de moi parce que parce
qu'elle aura vu que j'ai brisé l'écart
quand j'ai fait bouger les lignes et
même parfois j'ai influencé des gens et
rien que pour ça je crois que ça valait
vraiment le coup d'en avoir du courage
[Musique]
et
bon